ce sont 21 élèves qui ont plus
rencontrés à la librairie entre
guillemets à la queue-lez-yvelines
hélène gaudi écrivaine grâce à la
quinzaine de la librairie organisé par
la région ile de france
ces lycéens ont découvert la profession
d'auteur franchement c'était super ça
fait plaisir de rencontrer un auteur
dont on apprécie le livret moi j'ai
apprécié l'histoire et je suis très
content d'avoir participé à ce projet
moi je les trouvais très intéressant de
bas après avoir lu livre d'avoir le
point de vue de l'auteur en plus du
point de vie que nous on a pu avoir du
livre et d'échanger sur comment est ce
qu elle a ressenti libre et comparée du
coup avec nous et que peut-être les
messages que nous on n'aurait pas
compris en lisant le livre black eyed
peas nous les transmettre en plus c'est
que ça complète un peu la lecture qu'on
a eu du livre puisque les lycéens avant
de rencontrer l'écrivaine ont lu son
dernier ouvrage un monde sans rivage
écrit à partir des photos d'une
expédition polaire datant de la fin du
19e siècle puis ils ont travaillé
l'oeuvre sous forme d'écrits d'invention
je pense que pour eux ça rend les choses
concrètes salle et ça les fait
rencontrer les vraiment les écrivains
sur lesquels on travaille voit qu'il ya
une vraie personne derrière un vrai
travail un vrai métier une vraie
recherche pour écrire les livres qu'ils
ont aussi parfois des questions même
matériel sur le métier d'auteur un
moment pour sensibiliser les jeunes à
l'univers de la lecture et un partage
d'idées aussi pour l'écrivain toutes et
tous ils ont vraiment
on voit qu'ils se sont vraiment investis
dans cette histoire que se sont
appropriés et ça c'est vraiment émouvant
et précieux pour quand on écrit je pense
de de voir que l'histoire lit les images
passent de de notre tête affaires des
autres et que ensuite elles produisent
encore d'autres d'autres textes d'autres
images c'est vraiment très très précieux
les échanges sont importants
l'image de marque est importante donc
forcément c'est toujours un plus pour
notre boutique de voile à participer à
ce genre d'organisation d'autres temps
des changes sont prévues dans les
yvelines comme à la librairie comme un
roman à chatou mercredi 26 mai avec le
lycée allant du vésinet ou à la
librairie la suite à versailles avec le
lycée jules ferry de versailles le
vendredi 28 mai